hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in part three of his on the basis of
morality the second main set of topics
that arthur schopenhauer
is going to examine are what he calls
anti-moral
incentives
and
he's going to begin by talking about
egoism or
you could call it self-centeredness
selfishness
and he tells us that the chief and
fundamental incentive in man as in the
animal is
egoism and he gives it a very quick loss
there the craving for existence
and well-being this drive
for continuing one's existence and for
making one's existence
better to enjoy it and he goes on
in a little bit more detail
shortly after that when he says by its
nature egoism is boundless
man has the unqualified desire to
preserve his existence so there we see
that part again to keep it absolutely
free from pain and suffering now that's
a new
part to it as well
which includes all want and privation
right so now we've got two parts to it
he desires to have the greatest possible
amount of well-being said just a little
bit earlier and
every pleasure of which he is
capable in fact where possible
he attempts to develop within himself
fresh
capacities for enjoyment so we've got a
lot of moving parts to this fundamental
drive and incentive to our actions our
motivational structure
here schopenhauer is not saying
something that
is radically new i mean there's other
people who have said similar things some
of them even using this basis to later
on argue that we can extend this to
others to all humanity in general the
stoics for example in their conception
of oikiosis
we begin with our own desire for
self-preservation and making our being
better and very quickly this extends to
other human beings for schopenhauer no
we are sort of stuck within
our own little world of this as he's
going to say later on
in his subjective view a man's own self
assumes these colossal proportions what
is that everyone is in all in all to
himself he finds himself to be the
holder and possessor of all reality
nothing can be more important to him
than his own self and then he says in
the objective view it shrinks to almost
nothing to a thousandth millionth part
of the present human
race right so we've got this uh he uses
microcosm and macrocosm
there and so this is uh something really
quite uh
important in schopenhauer's ethics not
because he's advocating this
but because he's saying this is what we
got to deal with
and he goes on and he says we can make a
distinction here
the word the word eigennewt
self-interest
denotes egoism insofar as this is under
the guidance of the faculty of
reason so this is something
distinctively
human egoism all animals have that
including us human beings self-interest
that's us human beings because we have a
faculty of reason what does this allow
us to do by means of reflection this
faculty enables egoism to pursue its
purposes systematically
in a you know reasonable fashion
thinking about priorities planning for
the future
considering means and ends learning
lessons i mean animals can do that to
some extent but not to the extent that
we can and so he says we call animals
egoistic
but not
self-interested and i'm going to retain
this word egoism for the general concept
and then he says something very
interesting here
in the animal
as in man this egoism is most intimately
connected with their innermost core and
essence in fact
it is
really identical with essence this is at
the core or the essence of what a human
being
is a human being and he says as a rule
therefore all of a human being's actions
spring from egoism and we must try to
explain a given action with this in
mind in fact you know when we try to
direct a person towards some goal or
another we appeal to their egoism if we
want it to be
effective
and so then
that's interesting
what else can we say about this well
what opposes
a person's egoism what it is that they
desire whether it's in terms of
existence or even just like perceived
threats to existence or their well-being
they're enjoying pleasures they're
avoiding pains and troubles what opposes
that is going to
generate or create a counter-response of
affects and conflict he says everything
opposing the strivings of his egoism
excites his wrath anger and hatred and
he will attempt to destroy it as an
enemy
and if possible he wants to enjoy
everything to have everything but as
this is impossible he wants to control
everything now
you know if there was only one human
being in existence maybe this wouldn't
be that big of a problem but
if i'm egoistic in that way and you're
egoistic in that way and we have to live
together you and i are going to sooner
or later
arrive at some conflicts right
and so he says everybody makes himself
the center of the world and refers
everything to himself
and then
he says there's no greater contrast than
that between the profound and exclusive
interest everyone takes in his own self
and the indifference with which all
others as a rule
regarded there's even a comic side to
seeing this we can look back and laugh
at this so
what is going to
oppose
this egoism he talks about the
possibility
of you know external forces and so you
know he says that um egoism shows itself
in everyday life always peering out of
some corner in spite of the politeness
which like a fig leaf is used to cover
it up politeness is the conventional and
systematic denial of egoism in the
trifles of daily intercourse certainly
recognized as hypocrisy yet called for
and commended because what it conceals
is so unpleasant no one wants to see it
so there's that right and so we have the
fear of
social
disapproval we we're nice to each other
we restrict our egoism we also do so so
that we don't get in trouble with the
authorities right the state he's going
to talk about quite a bit which can
punish us for doing injustice to other
people now if these factors go away
schopenhauer says watch and see what
happens people will
behave in all sorts of completely
self-interested ways
if you don't oppose them the other thing
that could oppose it though is
some sort of
genuine
moral incentive as he says
where egoism is not opposed by an
external force
which must include all fear of human or
supernatural powers or by a genuine
moral incentive it pursues its purposes
without reserve and without any checks
this would lead to the
balum omnium contra omnes that is the
war of all against all a reference to
hobbes's state of nature in
leviathan and you know we do see this
happen in many cases
schopenhauer is also going to talk about
two important virtues here that he
thinks are going to be central
to morality and he's going to unpack
later on in this part of his work he
talks about
justice
the virtue of justice and he says which
in my opinion is the first and really
cardinal
virtue the virtue from which other
virtues
flow and he says that this opposes
egoism now of course many instances of
doing justice to other people could in
fact be just you know self
self-interested right i do so to avoid
the state coming down on me i don't
steal my neighbor's goods well that's
not the virtue of justice that's just
doing justice that's not yet having that
as part of your motivational structure
very important difference there
another
virtue that he brings up is philanthropy
or loving kindness
which is opposed to ill will or
spitefulness
and he's going to go into an analysis of
this before we do that though before we
look at that analysis
there is something that we want to
highlight
so egoism a little bit later on he's
going to talk about as a brutal that's
the word that he's using
uh root
of
bad actions of it's an anti-moral
incentive or an anti-moral motivation
right
what does he mean by brutal
we often think of brutality and we
equate it with something like cruelty
which schopenhauer is going to say no no
that's something different here it's
behaving like an animal just following
out our own
self-interest
to the detriment of others typically
ill will
is going to be a devilish diabolical
route
and
that is something that
in many respects i think you can say is
only there for rational beings
human beings
and there's a difference in how they
approach
ends and means
in this
he tells us
this is uh
quite interesting
that the
ways in which these work
is a bit different the
end
of egoism is to get what you want and if
other people get in the way so much the
worse for them right they should have
known better than to oppose you
the
end the goal of ill will
is
harm to another
damaging another hurting another
depriving them humiliating them
so this is different the egoist the
person who's being driven by primarily
egoistic motives in this case selfish
motives may humiliate somebody else but
it's to get something else
whereas the ill will person will do so
just
to hurt the other person for that point
consider how it might work if you wanted
to argue somebody out of bullying other
people if they were motivated by egoism
which couldn't include you know the the
need for security on their own part well
you can try to provide them with a
different means to the end that they
want
somebody who has ill will
they want to hurt that other person they
want them humiliated and you're not
going to actually argue them out of it
except perhaps by guiding them to do the
same thing to others now how does ill
will arise this is quite interesting so
egoism is
just part of our nature right how do we
wind up with ill will
he says that
it happens
through
several different
things
one is
when
we
wind up in conflict
with other people right he says that
here we go
ill yeah ill will in its lower degrees
is very frequent quite unusual and
easily
reaches the higher it arises from the
inevitable collisions of egoism that
occur at every step so
we can start out with a war evol against
all or let's just call it uh conflict
between people over their egoistic
desires and plans
and then
inevitably the the fighting against each
other the friction the conflict is going
to produce in some of them ill will you
stop just seeing the other as an
obstacle and you start seeing them as an
antagonist that you want to
destroy in some way another very
interestingly
arises when we witness
the faults of others and perhaps even
ourselves
he says it's also objectively stirred by
the sites of vices faults weaknesses
follies shortcomings and imperfections
of every kind which everyone more or
less exhibits to others at any rate
occasionally so these could be as
trivial as like the
dislike of how somebody eats you're with
them for a while and you're like can't
you keep your mouth shut when you're
chewing or something like that and then
you you start to really dislike them and
maybe
hate them and say a cutting thing right
there's one other thing that that he
brings up here as well
envy
he says that
[Music]
envy is one of the main sources of ill
will or perhaps envy itself is ill will
that is excited by the happiness
possessions or advantages of others it's
most poisonous and implacable when
directed to personal qualities since
here the envious man is left without any
hope and it's at the same time it's most
vile
because he hates what he should love and
respect we see other people
having something good and we feel ill
will towards them
as a result a little bit later on he's
going to analyze envy and he also calls
uh this
sharden freuda that you're all familiar
with this term i think by now because
people are always oh the germans have
this word that we can't translate into
english no we can translate it just fine
malicious joy in the sufferings of
others or the damage of others or the
humiliation of others he says in some
respects the opposite of envy is the
malicious joy at the misfortune of
others
yet to feel envy as human but to indulge
in such malicious joy is fiendish and
diabolical there's no more infallible
sign of a thoroughly bad heart than an
inclination to sheer and undisguised
malignant joy
of this kind and then he goes on and he
says something really curious
envy and malicious joy
are merely theoretical
right
in practice
they become
malice
and
cruelty
and here's where he talks about the
difference between ends right malice and
cruelty
the pains and sufferings of others are
an end in their in themselves and their
attainment is a pleasure for the
malicious or cruel person
the maxim of
malice is injure all people as much as
you can
he provides some brief sketches saying
you know we could do an entire
discussion of this but i'm just going to
list
these off at this time
what arises
from these two fundamental
forces he says
such a system would derive from egoism
greed
intemperance lust
selfishness avarice covetousness
injustice hardness of heart pride
arrogance
and so on so obviously this is not a
comprehensive list but this gives you an
idea of what falls under
egoism
what arises from ill will
he says
envy
disaffection ill will malice malicious
joy and others misfortune
prying
curiosity slander insolence petulance
hatred
anger
treachery perfidy thirst for revenge
cruelty
and
so on so
these can lead to a lot of important
problems
and then he you know is going to finish
up by saying okay is this all that we've
got going on with human beings you know
we can try to restrict them and a lot of
what we call justice which is not really
the virtue of justice and a lot of
actually what we call philanthropy or
loving kindness which is not really the
virtue of just certain actions
you know we can restrict this sort of
thing
quite a bit through making people afraid
by telling them all sorts of stories
about the gods and what they're going to
do but these these are really just
appeals to egoism you know be good or
the gods are going to take vengeance and
impose justice upon you
that's just an appeal to you getting
what it is that you want or not getting
what it is that you don't want from
other people and he says
what would get us beyond this
motives of such a kind always rooted
in mere
egoism and he says here we actually have
to
think
philosophically right um and we also
have to be very careful he says many a
man can give an account to himself of
his noblest actions only through motives
of the kind previously
described but it is certain that he
nevertheless acts for much nobler and
pure incentives though it may be much
more difficult to make these clear out
of direct love for his neighbor he
actually does what he is only able to
explain by the command of his god but
philosophy
can actually look at the nature of human
beings independent of all mythical
interpretations religious dogmas and
transcendent hypotheses there's a
rejection of conscient ethics and other
ethics that's built into this as well
he tells us philosophy demands to see it
what's the it this genuine morality
demands to see it demonstrated in
external or internal experience so this
is a philosophical task he's not yet
telling us
what this would be
but he's suggesting that there is
something that can go
beyond this and resist these motives
you